الاخبار اهلا بكم صدق الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
بالقراءتين الثانيه والثالثه على الغاء
بنود في قانون الانفصال حديث الجانب من عن
قطاع غزه واربعين مستوطنات شمال الضفه
الغربيه وذلك بعد 18 عاما من اقراره يهدف
التعديل الذي اصبح نافا الى الغاء بنود
كانت تحضر على المستوطنين دخولا نطاق اربع
مستوطنات تم اخلائها في الضفه الغربيه عام
2005 على نحو يتيح اعاده توطينها من جديد
وكانت الخارجيه الاردنيه استدعت سفيره
اسرائيل في عمان بعد تصريحات لوزير
الماليه الاسرائيليا عدم وجود شعب فلسطيني
واستخدامه خريطه لاسرائيل تضم الاردن
والاراضي الفلسطينيه وصفت الخارجيه
الاردنيه استخدام الخريطه بالتصرف العنصري
والتحريضي
قال حاكم القرمه الموالي لروسيا ان
الدفاعات الجويه بشبه الجزيره تصدت لهجوم
الاوكراني بالمسيرات بمدينه جانكوي ما ادى
الى اصابه مدني نتيجه سقوط حطام مسيره
اوكرانيه على منزله وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه قالت
في المدينه الشماليه شبه جزيره القرم دمرت
صواريخ كروز كاليبر
يواصل الرئيس الصيني
حيث تبدا بعد ظهر اليوم المباحثات الرسميه
في قصر الكرملين بين الوفدين برئاسه رئيس
البلدين ومن المرتقب ان يتم توقيعه في
نهايه القمه على مجموعه من الاتفاقات
المشتركه وكان شيوى بوتين قد اجريا امس
مباحثات استمرت لاربع ساعات ونصف تناولت
مسائل التعاون بين البلدين وملفات الدوليه
والاقليميه على راسها الحرب في اوكرانيا
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيين هو مع
احتفال التونسيين بمرور اكثر من 12 عاما
على ثورتهم تظل الولايات المتحده ملتزمه
بالحريات الاساسيه والمؤسسات الديمقراطيه
والحوار السياسي الشامل
لن تقبل اي تدخل خارجي في شؤونها مره اخرى
واضاف خلال زيارته الى ولايه القيروان وسط
البلاد ان تونس لن تفرط في سيادتها لاحد
لانها ليست تحت الحمايه ولا الانتداب وفق
تعبيره
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]